الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه سيطرتها بشكل
كامل على مدينه نوفودونيت في مقاطعه
دوناتك من جهه اعلان الجيش الاوكراني انه
سعاده السيطره على بلده
بيتا جنوب غربي مقاطعه زابوريا وذلك بعد
معارك استمرت اسبوعين لتصبح تلك البلده
الثامنه التي يسيطر عليها منذ الهجوم
المضاد للمتابعه معنا من زابولوجيا
مراسلنا حسان مسعود اذا حسان
ثمن بلده يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني
ولكن بالحديث عموما عن الهجوم المضاد يبدو
ان الامور لا تسير كما كان او كانت تتمنى
القوات الاوكرانيه
نعم حسن التطورات على طول الجبهه الممتده
والتي تشون القوات الاوكرانيه ما تسميه
بالهجمات المضاده على عدد من المحاور على
ما يبدو ان التقدم عبر هذه المحاور هو
بالامتار ابعد الاماكن التي تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه على لسان نائبه وزير الدفاع
انها وصلت اليها منذ اسبوعين منذ بدء هذه
الهجمات المضاده هي بعمق سبعه كيلومترات
فقط على طول هذه الجبهه ما يعني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت بعيده للغايه عن اقرب
المدن التي كان من الممكن ان تصل اليها في
حال نفذت هجوما مضادا واسعا على الاقل
مثلا توك ماك هي بعيده حتى هذه اللحظه عن
خط القتال الاربعين كيلو مترا مثلا
ميليتوبل حوالي ال65 كيلومترا
حوالي 100 كم وكذلك ماريوبل هذه المناطق
الاساسيه التي حاول القوات الاوكرانيه
التقدم باتجاهها وفق التصريحات الرسميه
لكن الخطوات التي تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت حتى هذه اللحظه خطوات
بسيطه قليله وهي تتجه عبر اكثر من محور
على ما يبدو وفق قوي الخبراء العسكريين
هنا ان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تبحث عن
الثغرات المناسبه للتقدم نحو احدى المدن
الكبرى على طول هذه الجبهه الممتده بحوالي
اكثر من 650 ميل منذ
ابتداء من مدينه باخموت من تلك المنطقه
الواقعه في اقصى الشرق بمقاطعه
ووصولا الى المناطق الواصله الى هذه
المناطق تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه التقدم
عبرها ولكن تقول انها سيطرت على بلدان
صغيره اقرب هذه البلدات التي اعلنت
السيطره عليها وهي ثامن بلده هي بلده تقع
في المنطقه الغربيه لزبولوجيا ونستمع لما
اعلن عنه
الكتيبه التي كانت تقاتل في تلك المنطقه
من الجياش الجيش الاوكراني والقوات
الاوكرانيه في هذا المقطع الصوتي
في اليوم الثامن عشر من حزيران تمكنت قوات
الوحده
1828 الهجوميه من طرد القوات الروسيه من
باياتاخاتكا الروس هربوا وتركوا المعدات
ومستودعات الذخيره
شكرا لك حسن مسعود